welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down She-Hulk episode 7. it's
full of Easter eggs hidden details and a
lot of callbacks of the comics that
we're going to be going through bit by
bit in this very video after the
Daredevil tease in episode 5 we were hit
with an inconvenient wedding episode and
it made me want to become the Joker all
in all She-Hulk is just another Marvel
show teasing a devil and we're gonna put
that to the side and take this for what
it is if you enjoy the video then please
hit the thumbs up button and don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns like
this every day by the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
She-Hulk episode 7.
foreign
[Music]
getting in touch with her in a She-Hulk
at blonsky's meditation clinic however
it could also be used with Josh as well
to show how he Retreats away from Jen
after getting her Goods so sorry her
body fluid sorry her DNA potentially now
we start off with a bird's eye view of
Chen's bathroom and similar Miss Marvel
we get texts presented in animated form
she is currently texting Josh and we get
a split second shot of the conversation
in which he talks about how hot her body
is he's also constantly asking where her
address is and hinting towards finding
out where she lives this obviously ties
into how he's part of the intelligenture
which goes back to our Theory last week
in which he was spying on her at the
wedding he ends up getting it shows up
to pick her up and he sits on the car
like it's a classic Date Movie got a lot
of Top Gun Marek buys from this and she
has clearly fallen for him Jen seems
really happy and over the top of this we
hear no I'm in it by Heim as she walks
around her apartment this entire scene
is sort of similar to the music video
for the song which has similar shot it's
in it and it is sort of a montage our
work she talks about getting fries with
him and to pay rate them at the wedding
last week this is something Jen is
constantly done with dates and she also
got fries to go in episode 4 after she
hit it off with that guy Shirley fries
though surely they're the side dish
because I don't know get get a burger or
something but either way they constantly
keep dating however Jen teases him and
doesn't let him come into the house to
penetrate her with his needle eventually
she does though and she stays in the Gen
form not having to revert to She-Hulk
this was a big part of the comics too
with her feeling like she couldn't be
with men as how she truly was in the end
Josh does the Hulk smash and dash and
ghosts her like it's Ant-Man in the WASP
at the end of the episode we learn the
truth of what really happened and watch
as he duplicates her phone just in the
same way we had triple emojis earlier
when she Hulk was at work we get them
here too and it's clearly him texting
the intelligent share I very much get
the feeling here that he did take her
blood and if our thoughts about the
leader being behind this are true I
think Josh is one of the his minions
that has potentially already taken it or
he's just doing some Recon to show when
she's most vulnerable I think stabbing
her might make her transform into
She-Hulk so he may not have done it but
let me know your thoughts below either
way she's clearly hung up on him too as
she's constantly pining after him like I
am with Daredevil
even getting nominated for female lawyer
of the Year doesn't help though we all
know she would easily lose to Kim Wexler
as talks about going to a Gala I'm
guessing this will be where the finale
takes place due to the sparkly dressed
scene that pops up in the trailer
intelligent chair is once more a
conversation topic and Nikki also brings
up a wellness Retreat for shadowing
what's to come much like the deleted
yoga scene from The Incredible Hulk we
watch as Jen tries to take her mind off
not getting reply but like Miss Piggy
she's in a Cell she can't escape the
traps of her mind no matter how many
bars she can bend or how many bars she
goes to on a bender no no it was pretty
bad now she does however get a call from
blonsky's parole officer AKA Chuck
Donald in this could be a reference to
Charles stunline a Marvel comic book
artist who helped to Pioneer this genre
blonsky's inhibitor has had a
malfunction and Chuck wants to go in
with some backup in the form of She-Hulk
she travels out of the Wilderness and I
got a lot of flashes back to the opening
of the series with hair and Bruce
traveling down the road she's listed
thing to Hansen even though she can't
get her mind off the handsome Josh
because she wants some um bop whatever
that means the needle joke was better
but the pair meet at summer Twilight in
the end everything seems like it's okay
with Blonsky saying he jumped it on
electric fence for his chicken silk
Bella at this point we meet two new
characters in manball and El aguiler as
man bull says he was created in the lab
and the comics had him kidnapping people
off the streets for a man named Mr Klein
Klein was carrying out experiments in
order to transform people into animals
and under the name William Torrens he
came face to face with Daredevil
Daredevil managed to stop him however
Klein wanted blood and as a punishment
for his failures he forced William
through the experiment which changed him
into man bull man bull is played by
Nathan Hurd and you might recognize him
for his stand-up comedy stuff as well
Aguilera this once more brings mutants
into the MCU after a mortal man showed
up last week born in Spain he ended up
traveling to America under the name and
he became a crime fighter for the poor
he was recruited by numerous government
agencies over the years though was
believed he lost his powers on m-day
however he kept getting work and we
learned that both are here to work out
their anger issues because El Aguila is
similar to a matador it represents the
people that have tried to oppress man
Bull and thus he lashes out and gets
angry in order to deal with his issues
Jen's car is destroyed and Tim Roth just
constantly cracked me up with his
Newfound positive outlook though he
wasn't announced as being part of the
Thunderbolts I am hoping that they held
him back because they wanted to keep it
as a surprise due to the show still
airing would love to see him pop up in
that film and work off the rest of his
parole I think Abomination is too good
of a character to leave here so
hopefully Val pops up in a post-create
tease Jen says she needs to get some
work done but she's clearly just trying
to get reception Wi-Fi in the hopes that
Josh takes her she wonders The Retreat
to the song peppers and onions by Tyra
whack and eventually stumbles across a
therapy session this is a bummer stay
which is of course a play on Namaste the
calming phrase said earlier in the
season it means greetings to you and we
can see it's a self-help center almost
elevating him like a cult-like figure
the other guy seems too chill to be
worshiped even with his seven wives and
they have several objects here to keep
people calm and also a chicken jar so
that blonski can buy more reminded me a
lot of the group therapy session from
Wreck-It Ralph with lots of characters
all giving their truths about how it
feels to be a villain that wants to
change you also meet porcupine a
character from the comics who was a
scientist that worked for the United
States Army he built a battle suit that
contained razor sharp spikes and this
suit is capable of shooting the needles
from it whilst also making him very
difficult to hit he thought the suit
would bring him a fortune but the
government refused to pay him and thus
he turned to Crime he pretty much
suffers from the fear of leaving his
suit here and refuses to take it off
initially now next is saracen who in the
comics was a mercenary figure that based
up against the Punisher several times
the best of my knowledge he was never a
vampire felt they could be using Emir to
foreshadow the arrival of Blade Jen
doesn't want to get involved but we
overhear the issues that they go through
and she decides to open up like she did
for Josh bellagula hates that he's
constantly seen as a matador when he
really wants to be noticed for who he
truly is lastly they're joined by none
other than The Wrecking Crew Leader
wrecker and though I would have been
like yeah mate who hired you Jen doesn't
do that now she does however lash out on
him but we learn that he's a changed man
this could explain why Josh wasn't with
the original group and he may replace
Wrecker in the team he talks about his
magic robot and in case you don't know
in the comics the group all held on to
one as it was struck by lightning this
gave them magical abilities whereas here
they stole him off an Asgardian
construction worker he's going deep and
finally facing up to what he did and
taking accountability Jen tells the
group about Josh and we discover that
she's now playing directly into letting
him take the upper hand by not texting
back a man saracen actually Cracks the
Case but he's shut down like a a tweet I
dropped in August saying that Hugh
Jackman would come back I think that we
have to start considering the very real
possibility that you were ghosted or he
wanted your blood no also I was right
yeah I was [ __ ] right you look at
that I was [ __ ] right either way this
insecurity has made a thing that she's
basically constantly losing out to
She-Hulk whenever she's gen nice little
detail here that only mean Quentin
Tarantino noticed is that She-Hulk
doesn't have shoes on she would of
course destroy her shoes transforming so
it's nice that they kept this detail in
the whole situation with Josh has made
her feel even more worthless however the
group left her up you know what for his
Stone faces have been throughout
She-Hulk a man saracen had me laughing
out loud with this bit because I bet Jen
is pretty damn great
and tasty oh damn it went off the rails
finally Jen realizes that maybe Josh
isn't for her but that there are men who
will genuinely like her and it's a
wonderful wonderful scene that actually
explores both sides of the character I
know of being constantly ragging on this
show for how hollow it feels but hey
this moment was really well put together
I think and in the end it inspires
porcupine to finally remove his mask
smells like crap though cause the guy
hasn't washed but hey you know what you
seem like a nice guy Jen accepts Josh
isn't worth her time and in the end she
finally deletes his number as a car is
turned away we can also catch the name
slot on it and this is a reference to
dance slot who created the She-Hulk
comic book run that the series is based
on think the driver might even have Dan
on his name badge but it's too difficult
to fully make out though it does begin
with a d The Gang sorry group say their
goodbyes and she rides home to a bit of
Dua Lipa however the episode isn't over
and we witnessed the other side of the
Josh thing with us seeing what really
happened
now the intelligenture are probably
going to tie into things further down
the line and I suspect that they're
going to be popping up in Captain
America new world order the leader has
been confirmed as popping up in that
movie and the idea of a new world order
of course ties in with the Illuminati
the illumawati not that one but this is
the idea that I feel is also behind the
intelligent share this super group of
super smart villains all pool their
resources and start to control world
events behind the scenes seems like
Marvel is doing a comment on the
internet and message boards being used
to indoctrinate young men and I think
the leader might become a figurehead for
this I doubt that the intelligenture are
going to be completely introduced and
defeated in the time we have left in the
season so I can see it being more of a
lead-in this will likely set up the
events for the future and it's a bit
weird that they're going after She-Hulk
guessing it is commenting on men hating
women with powers and this will then
spiral off into other things Marvel
obviously always trying to bring social
issues into their movies so it's a bold
move cotton let's see if it pays off for
them now the members we know are coming
into the MCU are Murdoch the leader and
we know that they're coming soon Modoc
will be an Ant-Man in the WASP Quantum
Mania and I'm guessing that will end
with a tease to that there's also Todd
who judging by the rumors on the show
will be popping up again further down
the line potentially next week we've
constantly talked about him for ages now
and the Very fact that they have a
vibranium needle makes me think that he
had a hand in this I played the voice
comparison tons of times so go watch our
older breakdowns if you want to hear
that but I think he and the wrecking
crew member are one and the same the
needle was of course bent and then on
the date he ended up asking about a
vibranium one this will be able to draw
out more hulk blood and potentially go
direct to the leader we saw in the
Incredible Hulk how Hulk's blood end up
making him go through metamorphosis
nothing that he wants to create his own
Legion of Hulks through using Jen's DNA
this idea was set up all the way back in
episode 1 and it's nice that they have
this through thread here anyway after
the Josh reveal we carry the credits and
as always get some chord drawings that
sum up the episode code this includes my
man El Aguilar matadorian college is a
joke and also Jen meditating in the weak
box lastly we have porcupine taking his
costume to the dry cleaners whilst we
can clearly see that it stinks like this
episode hey I'm just kidding anyway that
ends the episode and as much as I've
been on the show I really enjoy this
week also you can probably hear I'm
losing my voice I've got a cold so uh
yeah I'll try and make this as quick as
possible now it was nice catching up
with the Abomination but I also liked
how he got the focus solely on Jen in
the past we've kind of had half the
episodes divided with characters like Mr
mortal Wong and some costume stuff and
yeah even even like the the Donnie Blaze
stuff it just detracts on what the main
focus is I prefer having an arc and this
tick to all the boxes for me where
they're having good jokes but all right
jokes some nice Side characters that
complemented the plot and also Jen
actually going on an arc where she lends
and grows my problem in the past is that
I felt something is missing from the
show and in comparison of the comics
it's been very surface level I felt like
it was a dumbed down version of The
Source material but yeah they really
Hammer home the cost of being She-Hulk
on gen rather than everything just
falling into her lap now I don't think
it was a complete home run and whether
it saves the series for me or not is
unlikely but this is an episode that
sets out to do a job and I think it
pulls it all together I still think
overall that the series has been pretty
poor and Noah said this on Twitter last
week people just started going off at me
and saying I just want cameos I really
don't uh honestly I don't care if
they're telling a good story and that's
what I feel this episode did I might be
in the minority of this as I had another
YouTuber text me immediately after the
show and say the episode sucked but I
thought it was all right mate I thought
it was okay might even say it twerked
for me and uh you could say that maybe
I've grown two we've all grown and I'm
finally gonna delete my incella gen
share profile either way that's my
thoughts let me know yours below and
hopefully see you next time where I'll
sound a bit better should be cured next
week I hope I'm stealing Jen's blood
either way we are in a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October and all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now save
that to you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers and call me an idiot he
wants me out to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of Ando which
will be linked on screen right now Jared
goes over the full episode talks about
his thoughts on it so definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for singing through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace
oh